we direct your attention to the left
field line for the entrance of the 2021
texas rangers hall of fame inductee
tonight both will take their rightful
hard-earned places
in rangers history tonight both will
become hall of famers
there are no words to describe
how honored i am to be a part
of this distinguished group
in texas rangers baseball history what
an honor to be conducted
this is your hall of fame this is unreal
what a great moment there's jordan lyles
on the mound for his 23rd start of the
season fourth time facing the oakland
a's this year
and there's a base hit i think the first
baseman lowe may have got a little
leather on that one
but marte has a base hit
and he swings and misses
that strikeout is the second out of the
inning
the runner at second and that'll bring
up lowry
and there is a line drive base hit down
the right field line marte's gonna score
easily it's picked up by garcia and
guess who comes through again jed lowry
a two-out rbi hit and the a's lead
one-nothing
and for the fifth time this season james
macrillion will take on the texas
rangers
and his first pitch this one lined over
second and into right field that's a
base hit and so yani is on a little
bluff coming around first base but he'll
settle for the single and there are two
outs now it's up to nathaniel lowe to
see that the rangers don't waste this
chance
[Applause]
speaking of third base when that one
blasted right past him and hernandez
rounds third he'll score low heads to
second with the rbi double and we're
tied at one so nathaniel delivers with
two outs then we got a new ball game so
here's chapman with one out we're in the
second is in the rangers one to one that
ball's belted deep to left field and
that baby's golf
chapman with home run number 15
and the a's take a two to one lead
boom
barrel to baseball exit stage left pack
your bags early chappie all aboard next
stop pound town
three two swing in the miss
and seth brown is epic
and this time he throws the bat for
strike three and that will win the
inning that's a dramatic strikeout
he's leading 2-1 the first pitch to hold
that one's floated into short left
center field and that's going to drop
for a baseline too far for machine to go
and martay wasn't able to get there so
it's a leadoff single for the brock star
there's a brilliant come set of the belt
in the pitch swung on that one's line to
left field that's the basis
the left fielder canna plays it on aha
both stops at second and the rangers
have two on with nobody out here in the
bottom of the third inning
and that one's hit well to left field
cannis going back cannon's gonna have
room
step toward the warning track and he's
got it side retired couple of runners
stranded fourth inning coming up
cued to the right side lowe's gonna go
to second back to first not quite in
time murphy beat it out so low
made the throw to kinder felefa it's a
good effort by low
3-2 runner goes two outs of the pitch
swinging a miss
fastball gotta might have been off the
plate but lyles gets the strikeout and
that completes the top of the fourth
it's a 2-2 count
and the pitch to brown that is hit in
the air to short left
jason martin trotting in underneath it
he's got it
3-2
and a swing and a miss he gets that
perfect fifth inning
two-two pitch
and this one flared out to right field
that drops in base hit
and it's opposo with his third
major league hit
pozo runs
and holt hits a little pop-up down the
third base line and champion caught it
he throws back to first and safe is pozo
what a play by matt chapman's
sensational effort
well the minute that matt chapman wants
it there's a residency in las vegas for
this magician waiting
incredible over-the-shoulder effort
swipe at it gather it but he ain't done
he's gonna extend and make this
other worldly effort and pop up
and hunt that second out not pleased
with the platinum level of defensive
effort
he's hunting that second out
[Applause]
chapman's got this one fires to second
for one lowry on the first and that's a
double play so the defense shines for
the a's here in the bottom of the fifth
inning and that'll bring up olsson who's
struck out and bounced out he swings and
drives one to left center and martin the
left fielder back at the track over his
head over the wall and the a's take a
three to one lead
opposite field by olsen three to one a's
in the sixth number 30 for the a's first
baseman and the mats are putting on a
show in arlington tonight
one and one and there's a line shot to
center that's a base hit
a two-hit game for yanni hernandez the
rangers seem to be using much the same
approach they used successfully last
night against cole irvin
swing early in the count
that's a base hit into right field for
dulles garcia hernandez slams on the
brakes
near second base
back-to-back singles here with the sixth
inning
low the batter with an rbi double in the
first inning 2-1
and this one over third base that'll
drop in for a base hit here comes
hernandez he scores easily
and now the tying running scoring
position the go ahead run on base it's
three to two low delivers for his second
time tonight and andrew chaffin
has come on in a in a big spot i'm
batting right-handed against the lefty
first and third one out one pitch and
this one in the air that ball pretty
well struck carrying back to the wall
back there he'll make the catch
garcia tags he'll score on the sac fly
and we're tied at three
boy jonah just missed
getting that one over the fence jordan
lyle stays out there goes to work into
the seventh with mitch moreland leading
things off moreland drives one to left
field that's it well
and it is girl
mitch moreland goes the other way
another home run for the athletics and
they grab the lead right back 4-3 so
moreland is indeed heating up
the rangers do swing the bat 2-1 and
that is golf deep to left and matt
chapman has a two-homer night
off the facade of the second deck
you talk about putting on a power
display
the a's all over jordan lyles
hit their fourth home run tonight and
it's 5-3 oakland back to back in
arlington texas brett martin their 49th
appearance for the lefty
first pitch demarte
marte smokes one down the third baseline
so that'll get brown home
marte goes to second with an rbi double
two-out rbi hit six to three the a's
lead so here's olson
first pitch to matt olson and that's a
base hit to left field martin charges
martin will flip it back in as marta
scores easily
so
matt olson comes through he's got a
couple of rbis tonight and now it's
seven to three as the asia scored four
times here in the seventh seth brown is
over three
and that one is ripped to right and
that baby's gone
number 15 for seth brown boy these are
teeing off tonight 8-3 athletics in the
ninth
center field marte coming in and marty
grabs it and that is the ball game so
the a's bounced back after a loss last
night they win tonight to even up this
series at a game of peace